[Music]
Kim Kardashian is showing off a more
modest side it's not that serious guys
here's Kim looking like a serious
high-fashion model as the reality star
stuns in a new photo shoot for CR
fashion book in the interview mrs. West
who was famous for showing off her
curves says there's more to her than
meets the eye quote my soul inside is
kind of modest my closest friends know
that about me I want to wear things that
make me feel good about myself and still
feel sexy when it comes to feeling sexy
Kim has a signature go-to style
skin tight and bold like this neon green
latex dress she wore to 2chainz wedding
after the ceremony Kanye was in a
touchy-feely moon literally sweeping Kim
off her feet to carry her to the car it
seems the lovebirds also have a
spiritual bond related to their late
parents Rob senior and Don de Wes Kimye
believes birds are a sign from the
spiritual world Kim said quote when my
dad was sick with cancer we were laying
out by his pool and I said if you die
you have to come back in the form of a
bird adding Kanye took a picture of the
two black crows that are always at our
house and always together we always say
that they are our parents hanging out
together at our house
[Music]
[Applause]